pas mon voilà le pot de miel
ici le fromage est très bien là l'os de
seiche et puis là les petites noisettes
très bien
tian bonjour à vous si vous êtes en
train d'observer casimir je me demande
bien ce qu'il est en train de fabriquer
avec tous ces produits
et bien il ne me reste plus qu'à
installer mais étiquette
elle met pancartes bon d'abord celle là
la part du papa papa papa remis par ma
femme pas mon papa me voilà parfait
distributions gratuites de nourriture
pour les animaux
et bien pour une fois c'est une bonne
idée vous trouvez pas voilà bien bien
bien d'abord l'écureuil as qu'est ce que
peut bien manger un petit écureuil
j'adore les petits écureuils qui vont
dans la forêt par un matin de soleil
printanier quand le il ya des reflets
roux dans leur fourrure à bien bon moi
l'écureuil va adorer ce petit poisson
voilà eh ben casimir se sent l'âme bien
poétique aujourd'hui vous trouvez pas
moi je suis pas persuadé qu'il ait une
bonne notion d nourriture préférée de
chaque animal bon le poisson rouge à un
joli petit poisson rouge qui montent et
descendent dans son aquarium dont le
fond est une symphonie de petits
graviers multicolores
quant à manger mon petit poisson ces
carottes
voilà il va adorer ces petites carottes
là alors là ça s'arrange pardon et le
lapin aux j'adore les petits lapins qui
vont dans la forêt avec leurs longues
oreilles et leurs petites que pointue
toute blanche
bon mon ami lapin va je pense beaucoup
aimé ce bel os de vote
voilà dix mois casimir
1 qu'est ce que c'est et bien tout
d'abord je te féliciter bralo c'est très
bien cette distribution gratuite de
nourriture pour les animaux
c'est une bonne idée n'est ce pas
excellente dix mois c'est monsieur du
snob
le président de la fête quitte à donner
tout ça oui il m'a demandé d'aller au
magasin est de ramener la nourriture
préférée de chaque animal et ben c'est
vraiment très bien qu'à peur jamais je
n'aurais cru capable d'un acte aussi
désintéressée oui pour une fois je n'ai
pas pensé à moi pour une fois bravo mais
quelque chose ne va pas que les miens
apprend quoi bien écoute je n'ai jamais
vu un écureuil manger du poisson
tu crois mais oui de même aucun des
poissons rouges que je connais
ne mangent des carottes j'en connais
beaucoup et bien suffisamment pour te
dire que la carotte n'est pas leur
nourriture préférée à ces affreux si je
me suis trompé tous les animaux vont
être déçus mais nova temps fait par an
les enfants vont nous aider casini
direct en mieux venez avec moi
venez avec moi en économie ils sont là
mettez-vous devant son comptoir
là vous êtes tous là regardez ce qu'il
ya sur la table pour casimir a apporté
toutes ces bonnes choses pour les donner
aux animaux
c'est gentil de sa part mais
malheureusement il ne sait pas quels
sont les animaux qui n'ont chacune de
ces bonnes choses ou les biens qu'on
l'aide
maintenant d'abord on passe en revue
tous cas sur le comptoir de casimir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça cet homme
c'est un homme un gros os de nos sa
moelle et ça qu'est-ce qui est là dedans
passé décrit la daphnie qu'est ce que
ces derniers ce sont des crustacés d'eau
douce qu'on appelle des puces d'eau
avant plus qu'une minuscule bien un bon
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est un
poisson à poissons tout frais ça dépend
des carottes
après quasiment
des noisettes sur l'assiette du fromage
de gruyère du miel et au bout on est au
bout d'abord commencé l'os de seiche en
os de seiche
12h - quasiment que cette boîte le ski
et ça c'est rien ça c'est à moi c'est
rien faut pas y toucher
bon bah écoute j'insiste pas un jeu pas
est un discret casimir je vois que tu as
préparé des étiquettes à la première
qu'est ce que c'est la tête pour le la
alors que d'après casimir le lapin ont
changé c'était vraiment je me suis
complètement trompé le lapin manche des
carottes
tu vois les prix changent les poissons
rouges mange des daphnies venise des
puces d'eau l'écurie mans l'écurie
limoges des noisettes dues à d'autres
étiquettes sont là les autres voilà
tient alors qu'est ce que tu as la
donnes tu as canada marie canaries alors
voilà le retient casimir dans celle de m
voilà arrangements coup tu vois là pour
m'aider des temps il se l'est fait le
vêtement de caméras sur l'os de seiche
comme çà et là la souris alors là
sourires l'amorçage le fromage les
souris sont très payante de froid
malzahn et de gloire et tous les autres
fromages le soyez gentils et garder du
manuel
parce que vous cachez te cacher la tige
qu'ils aient nos amis qui sont chez eux
alors que mon jeune ours guinée el tineh
casimir tu vas au bout du comptoir pause
et on y est
pour l'ours voilà un si c'est ça ensuite
que vimy alors d'accord et ensuite le
choc tient poissons et ben voila casimir
mézidon maintenant tu pourras peut-être
nous dire ce qu'il ya dans cette boîte
olaya ya juste quelques bananes écrasées
avec de la confiture de fraise et du
nouvel impôt mais un petit peu de
moutarde et une saucisse de toulouse
tiède mais cru comment tu affiné n'ont
fait que du mur c'est le gloubiboulga le
plat préféré des casimir us ben oui non
tu vois je me suis dit que peut-être un
casimir eu sa femme et passerait devant
mon stand et il faut que je la case mur
tu sais très bien que tu es le seul
casimir us à venir dans le jardin et
puis ici
ya que toi qui aimes le gloubiboulga ben
ouais et alors oh que ses murs
[Musique]